big moment have you seen this viral
moment so they put your face back to the
fetus the movies happening is it
happening totally you heard it here on
ET first man down it's happening we
start shooting in like an hour
you'd be interested I would I would not
be interested because that is a perfect
movie and when I first got spider-man my
goal was to be my generations Marty
McFly and when I did the first press
tour a journalist said to me they're
like you realize that you're like Marty
McFly in this movie and I was like done
I have a kiss dad 16th birthday what did
you get I don't know I know I went
waterskiing with all of my mates yeah I
don't remember what I got what did you
get on your 16th birthday I think of
like a crappy car from my dad Chris got
off football pads he said yeah a cause a
pretty great president I didn't get a
car fit round this movie is so much
about Brotherhood and I think that it
gives young men and boys a really cool
roadmap to like how they can be men in a
kind and light-hearted way what do you
hope them kids that we're looking for
Brotherhood story across the world
takeaway from this movie I think it's a
really nice way for young kids to learn
how to express their feelings and
express their emotions it's a film about
emotions and it's a film about
connectivity and I sometimes think that
like young boys especially have a hard
time expressing how they feel and I
think this film will really help people
sort of feel more comfortable doing that
and if that is something that we can do
then I think we've achieved something
really special
[Music]